5 signs of vitamin C deficiency and how
to get more vitamin C in your diet
vitamin C is an essential vitamin your
body requires for a healthy skin bones
blood vessels and a strong immune system
five common signs of vitamin C
deficiency include easy bruising and
slow wound healing due to impaired
collagen synthesis in the skin frequent
infections like coals and flu constant
fatigue and weakness bleeding gums and
frequent muscle and joint pains citrus
fruits like oranges lemons grapefruits
and limes are excellent sources of
vitamin C strawberry is another fruit
that is packed with this vitamin both
green and red bell peppers are very rich
in vitamin C kiwi fruit is also a
fantastic source of this vitamin dark
leafy greens such as spinach and kale
also contain good amounts of vitamin C
remember to stay curious and stay
healthy